bishop just cannot stop those two pawns  from marching and only ten seconds well  eleven  you called it ivanka he resigned there  it is the first win of the tournament  for magnus carlsen in the new in chess  classic the qualm liam had to resign  there against  the world champion and we see that was  the last game of round two all games now  finished all the games  uh going on down at the meltwater  studios and here magnus  running up the stairs going through the  resting area what do you think he's  gonna do now man  david it's got 15 minutes is it  preparation is it eating what will he be  doing um knowing magnus it's probably a  lot of eating  uh probably some noodles um but uh yeah  i think  uh i mean he he's the world champion for  a reason he's very professional and he  will  be having a look at the other game